first step in making a movie make it
that's it okay first step in making a
movie come up with an idea and and try
and figure out tailor the idea to the
budget you have and let's say the budget
is $1 well then make a $1 idea that just
because it's a $1 idea it doesn't mean
that it's only worth $1 but it means
that's all you have to spend you have to
come up with something that is that is
tailored to that idea like when I made
to Jennifer I knew since I was shooting
on an iPhone I was really only paying
for food because nobody was gonna stop
me filming wherever I went so it was
super gorilla
we filmed scenes on an airplane those
scenes on an airplane were actually
coming back from the the shooting
Virginia we filmed those on the airplane
the actual airplane and nobody nobody
would stop you because you're they're
filming with a phone they think you're
just making a little home movie so
tailor it to what you have and and just
realize that and then also put together
a group of people and if you can't find
a group of people that'll work with you
then find out what jobs that you're
gonna be able to do and you're gonna
have to do so when you made your first
film you knew you had 7,000 hours
how did you tailor that idea around a
$7,000 budget did you know okay I'm just
gonna have a couple locations just one
location the entire budget went to
effects craft services and buying oh
what did we buy buying sound equipment
oh and buying buying this so I could
edit it buying the computer with final
cut on it so that was the whole budget
was everything
you